you
look absolutely marvelous what a sight
good afternoon congratulations to this
wonderful class of 2012 exuberant
graduates relieved parents loving
friends and exhausted professors I am
really so honored that you've given me
the privilege to address me and what is
so special a day for you and special to
me as well my hats off to you
so I want to tell you first about this
hat when I arrived I was greeted by a
most wonderful and welcoming lady master
Pamela Lauren's and said to me would you
like to go upstairs and wash up and I
said I don't think I need to and she
said looking at me yes you're right you
already are washed up
anyway she made up for it this is her
hat so as you heard a few years ago I
wrote my memoir it was called audition
because to me life has been a continuous
audition and while writing the book I
had to do some research on my family
including my paternal grandmother Lily
whom I had never met she was evidently a
very elegant and fastidious woman and on
her deathbed she turned to her seven
children and told them that she was a
virgin and they said well how is that
possible we are here three sons and four
daughters you must have done something
with Grandpa and she said yes I did
but I never participated
so
so when I was asked if I would come here
today to talk with you I said to myself
these kids are smarter than I am these
kids are younger than I am they are
better educated but by god I am going to
participate
you know it's a daunting task because
I'm used to talking every day on
television
usually with four other women who
interrupt me all the time so today it's
a great joy to be able to speak
uninterrupted but I was trying to think
of what I could tell you that's going to
make the least bit of difference in your
lives even ten minutes from now when I
went to college I went to a very small
college called Sarah Lawrence back in
the Middle Ages I had a professor who
became very well-known his name was
Joseph Campbell and he exhorted us all
to follow our bliss do what you love
follow your bliss and you will truly see
successful well it was great advice
except when I graduated from college I
hadn't a clue what I really loved I had
no bliss to follow and so when I look at
all of you today I think many of you do
know what your bliss is graduate school
or medicine or law or biology ecology
sociology how about none of the above
how many of you in this graduating class
truly know what your bliss is raise your
hands
isn't that interesting not that great a
number how many of you do not know what
your bliss is raise your hands don't be
afraid most of us don't I didn't find my
bliss until I was in my 30s and then by
luck but that's another story so when
you walk out of here and everybody every
friend every family member says what are
you going to do what are you going to do
would just tell them you haven't yet
found your bliss I did finally find my
bliss and I have had a professionally
blessed life as you learned I've
interviewed every US president and first
lady since Abraham Lincoln the terrible
thing is that there are some of you out
there who really believe that but it's
really been since Richard Nixon and I
have interviewed world leaders from
Fidel Castro to vitomir Putin and this
past December Syria's Bashar Assad so I
should know something about leadership
and some message that I could give you
but I decided that what I could offer
you most today is the wisdom and the
stories of some of the most thoughtful
people that I have been fortunate enough
to talk with over the years so I think
their words rather than just mine may
help to answer your own questions and
your own quest for bliss much of what I
will talk to you about has to do with
choices and much of what you will be
facing tomorrow and in the years ahead
are choices so let's start at the top
with President Barack Obama as it
happens as you heard I interviewed him
in the view just this past Tuesday and I
asked privately if he had followed his
bliss and he said yes he became a
community organizer and then I asked
what jobs does he think are available
during these tough economic times and he
said the best jobs right now are in
science and engineering if that is your
bliss you are fortunate you will be
among the few with a job open for
but in the New Year interview I asked
the president what as a young man he
thought he would be doing this is what
he answered I had a bunch of different
schemes for a while I thought that I
might end up being an architect I like
the idea of building buildings I didn't
know what happened to that I still
really admire architects and I love
looking at buildings then for while I
thought that I might be a basketball
player until I realized that I wasn't
good enough to be a professional
basketball player I thought I might be a
judge
but then I decided after going to law
school that I was probably a little too
Restless to sit in the bench all day
long the one thing I know I didn't
expect was that I was going to be
President of the United States and I
said well when you've named all the
things you couldn't be the only thing
left is to be President isn't it and he
said yeah guess if you've got to find
some use for yourself this isn't a bad
way of doing it from President to a
woman who wanted to be president one day
she still may be and that is our
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton one
of them boasts one of the most admired
women in the world and her personal
story is very much about choices at one
point in her history she had one of the
biggest choices a person could make a
presidents fall from grace a marriage in
shambles a nation embarrassed this from
an interview with Hillary Clinton in
2005 your life has been about taking
chances and making choices mrs. Clinton
what was the biggest choice that you had
to make she said staying married to my
husband I'm often asked why bill and I
have stayed together all I know is that
nobody understands me better no one can
make me laugh the way Bill does even
after all these years he is still the
most interesting energizing and fully
alive person I have ever met everyone
has a choice every single day about how
to live your life and I know that many
people looking at my life would say oh
my goodness how tough I look at it
differently I look at the lessons that
I've learned the opportunities that I've
had
I asked what's the most important lesson
you learned she said that life is a gift
and that we learn as we go and that love
and hope and faith are truly the most
important gifts that we can have and
that we can give to one another and that
when something difficult happens you
have to decide what's important to you
what your priorities are and you have to
listen hard to your own heart there are
always going to be people who have
different ideas about decisions and
choices that you should make but
ultimately we are born alone we die
alone and the life we make the journey
we take is really up to us from Hillary
Clinton to the Dalai Lama
he's one of my all-time favorite leaders
a man without a country a man regarded
by many as a God who calls himself a
teacher and was given his title when he
was 2 years old the exiled Dalai Lama
after bed I went to talk with him and
Dom Salah in in India because as you
know he's been exiled from Tibet I went
because we were doing a two-hour special
called heaven where is it and how do we
get there and I talked to a great many
religious leaders from the different
faiths most said the purpose of life is
to go to heaven or to paradise the Dalai
Lama however when I asked said the
purpose of life is to be happy
and how do you get to be happy through
compassion he said and warm-heartedness
you achieve those qualities in part by
abandoning all negative thoughts and
feelings of competition so for about
three days after the interview I
practiced what the Dalai Lama had taught
me I practice compassion I was extremely
warm-hearted I was not jealous
I had no negative thinking I smiled a
lot I was so on hard
and I was exceedingly boring but in
truth the Dalai Lama did give me a lot
to aspire to his was not a lesson lost
compassion and warm-heartedness
so simple and so hard to do but I've
tried to practice both and while I'm
speaking of compassion I want to say a
few words to this graduating class about
friendship look around look at the
people next to you the people behind you
the people you see maybe the most
important takeaway of your years here
the friends that you have made here at
Yale maybe the best experience you could
have and they will continue to be a part
of your life long after you may heaven
forbid forget the name of your professor
and even whatever he taught you I have
little family I have one daughter my
friends and my family and your friends
have been the steady part of your
growing experience here at Yale treasure
them make the effort to stay in touch
with them beyond Facebook treat them
with compassion and warm heartedness and
do not lose your friends from your life
well I want to talk now about heaven it
all because men and women today are
faced with choices that a lot of your
parents and grandparents didn't have and
that is you want to have a private life
that's important as well as a career you
want to be involved with your children
you don't want to leave it up to Daddy
or leave it up to parents so how do you
have it all there are still choices that
you will make just one of the greatest
problems you will face and one of the
greatest joys and perhaps triumph is
balancing this life the career the
relationship whatever it may be the
children so I thought what I would do
really because I just love it and it's
fun to tell you about Katharine Hepburn
do you know she is good well some of
them is a ho weird work okay she was a
great actress she died in 2000
at the age of 96 and she was a beloved
icon in part because she was so definite
about everything and she kind of talked
like this and she was very definite and
I remember coming back from the Middle
East and we were talking about something
and she said I see things in black and
white don't you and I said I've just
gotten back from the Middle East I'm
afraid I see things in shades of gray
and she said well I pity you so I talked
with her she had married once very young
never married again and had a long
affair with the actor Spencer Tracy so
she had a great career she never had
children and she did not have a great
marriage and I said can you ever forgive
and a marriage and children and she said
you couldn't when I started at least you
couldn't have a marriage that would
please me because the ladies are going
to have to be careful that they don't
all marry morons and I said why she said
well because they don't deliver the
goods as wise I mean we're very confused
sexually very confused I mean look at
the birds and the beasts and the male
and the female and there are very
definite types we're getting awfully
confused I mean I put on pants 50 years
ago and declared a sort of middle road
you know but I mean I have not lived as
a woman I have lived as a man I said how
so she said well I've just done when I
damn well wanted to and I've made enough
money to support myself and I ain't
afraid of being alone I said is it so
hard to have it all the marriage the
children the career I said I think
myself it's very tough much of my life
has been a balancing act
she said it's impossible if I were a man
I would not marry a woman with a career
and I would torture myself as a mother
suppose a little Johnny a little Katie
had the mumps and I had an opening night
I'd want to strangle the children I
would really want to strangle the
children
and I'd be thinking to myself god I've
got to get into the mood and what's the
matter with him and then out of my wait
and see and I said if you were a man you
would not marry a woman with a career
she said I wouldn't be that big a fool
I'd wanted to be interested in me not a
career and a career is fascinating I
don't know what the hell the women are
going to do or the men so welcome to the
life of choices then my favorite part of
the interview did not have to do with
choices I said to her do you remember
the last time we talked I did something
that I have regretted ever since we were
talking about you're getting on and you
said which people don't remember he said
I'm like an old tree and I said what
kind of a tree and you said I'm like an
oak tree I said right everybody forgets
that you said you were like a tree and
on my obituary it's going to say she
asked people what kind of tree they want
to be why did she ask that wonderful
Katherine happened what kind of a tree
right and she said I wonder what kind of
a tree people are all the time don't you
do you ever wonder what kind of a tree
your best friend is well she said you
didn't mean that question she said I
look out and I know I'm not that damn
sycamore in the backyard that drops his
branches and his liable to kill people
and I'm not a silly piddling little tree
I'm a wonderful oak tree and I saw one
this big around in the woods
a white oak with branches that go right
through the wall great like that
symbolic that's okay
we'll take it off um we were talking
earlier when I was having lunch with
some of you about Margaret Thatcher and
I didn't write down her interview
because I didn't know how many of you
would remember her but then I realized
that there was a movie The Iron Lady and
what I learned for Margaret Thatcher was
how to live with failure because she had
been the first female prime minister the
longest reigning prime minister and then
her own party kicked her out and I
interviewed her right after she was no
longer Prime Minister and she was a very
depressed stage and she said you know
the telephone rings and I think I must
answer it and I must go back to Downing
Street and then I realize it isn't me
and she said it is so important and
you're so young now and you're just
beginning but you will I hope not but
you will perhaps um have some failure
and you will be able to go on add a new
chapter have a more interesting time
even when I went to ABC to be the first
female co-anchor of a network news
program I was a total flop the headlines
and the paper said Barbara Walters a
flop and I was an anguish but the best
thing that happened to me was that I had
to work my way back that's when I did
all the interviews that we've talked
about if you have a failure
you will rise you will be fine
you will work your way back do not sink
into why me what was me it's not my
fault and to give you an example of that
I want to read to you the words of a man
named Christopher Reeve I'm reading this
to you because life sometimes brings
enormous difficulties
and challenges that seem just too hard
to bear but bear than you can and bear
them you will and your life can have a
purpose Christopher Reeves life did let
me remind you of who he was he was a
fine actor he was famous for playing
Superman in films and he was a superb
athlete he sailed he skill he skied most
of all he was a great horseman until
1995 when his horse failed to jump over
a hurdle in a writing competition the
horse fell he fell with it and he found
himself completely paralyzed from the
neck down this man who had been this
adventurer and actor and athlete and his
wife came into him and she said Chris if
you want us we will find the way to pull
the plug and he was lying in bed with
the tubes completely immobile she said
remember you were still you which had
two connotations you were still you and
you were still you and she left the room
and a doctor came in in a white coat
with a heavy accent and the doctor said
I'm a proctologist turn over and we've
looked at this doctor as if he were
insane and the doctor said I told you I
told you turn over and as he was about
to try to find some way of getting a
nurse as someone instead of this crazy
doctor he looked up and he realised it
was Robin Williams he had gone to
Julliard with Robin Williams and he
burst out laughing and he said if I can
laugh I can live these are the words of
Christopher Reeve you gradually discover
as I'm discovering that your body is not
you and the mind and the spirit must
take over and that's the challenge as
you move from obsessing about why me and
it's not fair
and when will I move again and move into
well what is the potential and now I see
opportunities and potential I wasn't
capable of seeing because every moment
is more intense and valuable than it
ever was I've received over a hundred
thousand letters from all over the world
and it makes you wonder why do we need
disasters to really feel and appreciate
each other I'm overwhelmed by
peoplesupport of me
and if I can help people understand that
this can happen to anybody that's worth
it right there
so I really think being in a journey and
I said you think you will walk again he
said I think it's very possible that I
will walk again and if you don't then I
won't walk again as simple as that
either you do or you don't it's like a
game of cards he said and if you think
the game is worthwhile then you just
play the hand you're dealt sometimes you
get a lot of face cards and sometimes
you don't but I think the game is
worthwhile
I really do he got to the point after
years of doing exercise and experiments
where he could breathe without a
respirator in his throat and for the
first time because he didn't have the
tube in his throat
he could smell a rose or taste coffee
that was an enormous accomplishment and
he had some feeling in his chest and
when I hugged him the last time I saw
him he could feel the pressure he could
feel the hug he made a good life
Christopher Reeve did with his wife Dana
and their three children he lectured
directed films raised millions of
dollars in the consciousness of
scientists to promote research into stem
cells hoping that he would be able to
cure the thousands of people suffering
from spinal cord injury his life though
very hard had meaning and
Epis his death in October of 2004 was a
great loss so what have I tried to say
to you as you enter this brand-new
chapter of your life and what I hope is
going to be a long and fulfilling life
with a lot of different hats that you'll
be wearing don't worry about finding
your bliss right now not even our
president knew what his bliss was nor
did I one of these days to your own
surprise your bliss will find you but no
matter what you do don't be like my
grandma Lily participate be their full
force full heart full steam ahead
and in making choices when in doubt
trust your gut
does this feel right does this feel good
remember the decision is ultimately
yours alone to make remember this today
when you're talking with parents friends
grandparents the decision is ultimately
yours alone to make when jealous angry
or afraid
try compassion and warm heartedness
nourish your friends and finally
whatever hand you are dealt I hope you
will find the game with while I do and
really have I been happier with the hand
that I have been dealt than I am today
with the honor and pleasure of meeting
you I thank you and I hope that your
life will be like a great white oak I
thank you